ça dure presque deux heures c'est tout
simplement en se berçant devant donc sa
caméra qu'il donc livre ce testament
vidéo avec deux objectifs principaux
un coup les l'opération choc contre les
motards criminalisés et de faire casser
la condamnation de mom boucher et ceci
en est piquant de policiers comme deux
poteaux comme complices potentiels donc
de 2 roberge
on écoute votre reportage merci alain
quoi
c'est dans ce chalet qui renie pas l'onu
charlebois a enregistré son testament
vidéo qui dure une heure 48 et se réfère
un calepin de notes
le ton est ferme parfois même agressif
charlebois dit que le jour où l'on va
découvrir la vidéo il sera mort
il sait que la fin approche mais il
n'est pas triste il veut redorer le
blason des hells angels comme s'ils
étaient en mission charlebois revient
sur les meurtres des deux gardiens de
prison en 1997 meurtres pour lesquels
maurice mom boucher a été condamné à la
prison à perpétuité
il affirme que mon boucher n'a rien à
voir avec ces meurtres que c'est le
délateur stéphane godasse gagné qui a
agi seul charlebois veut forcer la
justice à reprendre le procès de mme
boucher charlebois prétend aussi que
l'ex-policier roberge lui affirmé que
dans l'opération sharqc qui a mené à
l'arrestation de plus de 150 motards
criminalisés
tous les rapports de police ont été
falsifiés le problème c'est que ce qui
est dit dans son testament et contredit
dans les enregistrements téléphoniques
entre roberge et lui roberge lui a dit
au téléphone que rien n'a été falsifiés
et que les reds seraient l'une des
dossiers d entente avec la couronne
charlebois affirme aussi dans son
testament film et que deux autres
policiers étaient d'accord avec roberge
pour vendre des informations ou à san
jose
ils étaient ensemble des complices leur
auberge
plus loin il explique que roberge avait
accepté de lui vendre des renseignements
parce qu'ils voulaient de l'argent après
le suicide de charlebois la police met
la main sur la vidéo et ouvre une
enquête sur robert il faut arrêter deux
jours plus tard charlebois était une
source code et de la police depuis 2006
il voulait que son testament soit
diffusée sur youtube sa charge
il était dans les systèmes reste à voir
quelle crédibilité accorder à ces
affirmations
gravel radio canada montréal